Peter King the Monday Morning
Quarterback mmqb and football night in
America is Peter King sport illustrated
Peter King Pete I've seen Paulie mad
before I've never seen him this angry
when he read the monday-morning
quarterback that you spent time at the
cabin with JJ Watt and Paulie and Paulie
was very very disappointed he didn't get
invited before you did so why is he a JK
wat guy oh my gosh now you're just being
dismissive Peter your great quarter you
should know better than that but I
thought we were tight he loves JJ Watt
they they exchanged pleasantries on
social media yeah that's nice yeah he's
got quite a place to say that the log
cabin is like saying out motel six is a
rich or something it's quite a little
log cabin he's got there ok but he did
talk about all of his injuries the the
column was about JJ Watt with his
injuries and how long he's going to play
and and didn't he sort of put a two or
three-year window here if it kind of
continues you know to be banged up the
way he's been banged up is that how it
was kind of framed yeah I mean he just
said in essence that um you know he
doesn't know what he's going to do and
but what he said I I said look I would
here's your chance clarify what exactly
you think you're going to do ok and so
because I've read a bunch of different
things he's he's gonna retire way before
his time he might retire so I just said
what what's the truth and he said I have
no idea what it's going to be and that
I'm not he said I'm not saying it's not
going to be two three or four years but
he said I'm also said it's I'm not
saying it's going to be nine or ten
years either um I mean I think his point
originally and his point now is that um
he's going to play as long as he can
play without a lot of pain
and as long as it's still fun and I
think that that means I think this is a
huge year for JJ Watt a lot more
important that a lot of people think
because last year was a disaster
physically he worked himself into being
too tremendously hurt and so will he be
Willie be as hurt this year or was that
a fluke thing last year where he had a
back injury a broken hand and he
practically tore his groin muscle from
the bone so this is going to be huge if
he has another year like that were every
week it's a battle just to be able to
get out on the practice field on
Thursday I mean who knows i think i
would change is mine so I'm going to
Peter King from the mmqb calm I just saw
this on the NFL network the Browns are
basically saying you want to come in and
get the number two pick its up for grabs
here what's that say to you about
Cleveland and anybody who's willing to
go up well I think I think first of all
it's true they're very much open for
business word out of that building is
that they were very interested in Jared
Goff and I think it's likely that golf
goes number one to the Rams but not
certain likely mmm but the Browns one of
the reasons why this is dan is that the
Browns want to give Robert Griffin the
third a real chance to be their
quarterback and I think there are those
inside the building who feel if we take
golfer when's here we're telling Griffin
that basically he's not the quarterback
of the future and I don't think they
want to do that yet so III think this is
a very tough position for the Browns to
be in and that's why it would be smarter
if they truly are going to give Griffin
a chance it would be smarter for them to
move down and aggregate sum pics and
maybe even uh you know trade to get
younger too
to get more pics I mean I would not be
shocked I mean I wouldn't I don't
necessarily expect that I wouldn't be
shocked to see them talk to somebody
about Joe Thomas so I think the Browns
are a very fluid team going into the
draft yeah I I would trade that pic and
trade down I do what Tennessee did
because you need a whole lot of help
there and and if you really believe in
rg3 then give him a chance unless you're
sold and you say look if we get Carson
wins we got our quarterback for the
future I don't know if the Cleveland
Browns can say that I don't think they
can I don't know that they can say it
either but I think the key thing is then
Q Jackson did not sign Robert Griffin
the third because he was saying okay
this will be our guy for the next year
while the guy who we draft while we get
him ready to play 2017 no Hugh Jackson
signed Robert Griffin the third because
he thought he has a more he has a
legitimate chance not just a twenty
percent chance a legitimate chance to be
a very good quarterback in the NFL and
you know that the two Jackson loves you
know he's kind of like a player in that
way he loves when people say you can't
do it or that's a dumb idea so I I think
this is very much infused character to
sign the lesser guy and to say we're
going to make a great player out of this
guy we had les Snead on the Rams GM
yesterday and he he said look we know
who were taken and when I pressed him on
it but he's still going to I guess
continue to have the facade here of he's
not quite sure if you're going to have
both of those quarterbacks in work them
out or have dinner with them what why
are the Rams being sort of clandestine
or secretive about this I park well I've
talked to see twice at length for story
i'm doing tomorrow uh at the mmqb about
how exactly this trade came about and uh
this sort of pic talk about how it ended
uh and it's it's very it's a very
interesting story but I I basically
asked
a lot of that of those questions and
also you know this this thing that you
know just because you need a quarterback
did you make your grades go up that high
so that these guys would justify the pic
and I think there's two things number
one I think the Rams believe that whence
and golf have grades that are very close
to Mario Dan Winston last year so they
do not believe that they're forcing this
they believe that at least one of those
guys and he said to me he said I'm
convinced that both of those guys will
be successful in the NFL so who knows
but they had dinner last night with
Carson Wentz in California and they're
going to see golf this week so why are
they doing it I guess I would look at it
this way Dan if you had a
franchise-changing decision you had just
traded six draft choices in the top
three rounds of the next to draft six
pics and you had two weeks before the
draft scope everything out why wouldn't
you want to even if in your building its
golf 55-45 let's just say and I don't
even know whether that's accurate but if
it is then don't you think it's it's
it's a good idea instead of just going
blindly into golf that they investigate
both what do they have to lose but what
are you gonna get out of a dinner
conversation that blew out there he said
they don't i I don't I don't know but
you know you can either do this you've
got two weeks before the draft you can
either sit in your cocoon and say I know
we're gonna pick there's no doubt about
it and blah blah blah or you can
investigate both guys and who knows
maybe something comes of this
investigation then I don't think they're
gonna change their mind either but this
is probably the way I would do it too i
would i would take the time and
investigate both guys fully which dinner
conversation would you
prefer to be a part of Carson when
surgery golf with the Rams uh at once i
think is a real fascinating guy he's
from Bismarck North Dakota in every
conversation he has he says he's going
to live in in North Dakota when he's out
of football he and yet and you always
think well this is going to be too big
for him you know and everybody I've
talked to about went in the NFL met him
and spent time with them I mean
everybody says Wow we think that he's
going to be okay with being a billboard
in in Sunset Boulevard or Cleveland or
Dallas or whatever that he's going to
handle that aspect of it just fine and
look I've only spent 45 minutes with the
guy so i cant i cant pretend like I know
him but he's he's one of those guys
you'd say well he played at North Dakota
State I mean how in the world can can
people feel like this guy can make the
transition and I remembered then at the
combine the day he worked out I talked
to the governor North Dakota and the
governor of North Dakota basically he
said to me that day said man everybody
in the state our buttons are just
popping here like he's the biggest hero
he might be the biggest hero to come out
of that state's into Roger Maris and so
you know in sports so I you know I don't
know I I think that he's had in his way
he's had a bunch of pressure on him
already p good to visit with you notes
busy time thanks for joining us thanks a
million Dan all about the Dan Patrick
show weekday mornings on audience